may I go ahead I can introduce topics to
[Applause]
[Music]
okay folks I brought Ryan back against
my better judgment and we're actually
gonna leap off from something that he
kind of mentioned offhandedly last time
I had him here and I can't remember how
many people in the comments said they
actually wanted us to do this it was
planting a seed yeah but I think they're
really like to be more like oh that
might be it just a light stroke we're
doing it anyway so we're gonna talk
about comic book properties I think
mostly we're focusing on Marvel that we
think not only should be made into
movies but more specifically should
really be done as animated movies yeah
and this was based on obviously upcoming
movie that we're both I think really
excited for is spider-man into the
spider-man increasingly the closer we
get to that the more yeah which is
obvious it's it's not an MCU feature
it's outside of the normal Marvel
Cinematic Universe but features of
character that everybody knows but also
the spin-off character Miles Morales but
I was thinking about that and that was
also thinking a couple of years ago with
big hero 6 Oh another really cool movie
using unused money mostly unheard of
Marvel properties but she's kind of
interjecting a good animated feature
about them so I was kind of thinking
what else could they do what other
properties might be more beneficial or
more fitting in the animated realm or I
mean just or other kind of stories that
would might like to just spin off that
way yeah okay so how many do you have
I've got three hard ones and then sort
of like a broader sort of umbrella one
that could spin into a lot of different
ideas okay well I've got three solid
ideas and then to kind of like
nebulous ones so Wow okay I'll start
with one that is a character who I
absolutely want to see in some form but
the
I think around the more I think nothing
live actions the way to go for this
character and that she hooked no oh no
no well see here's the thing I I
consider talking about geo because I
think if you were gonna do the Peter
David run if she hopes specifically that
should be animated but I still stand by
she-hulk should be a live-action TV show
but you do the the trial the lawyer
birth anyway we've talked about that
before
no no Squirrel Girl okay I was I was
thinking she was gonna I was he's either
gonna say she-hulk Squirrel Girl or MS
marvel but world girl between the the
nature of the humor and sort of it has
its little fourth wall breaking moments
I always think fourth wall breaks play
better in animation I do too because I
feel I feel like if nothing else Looney
Tunes I do bake to that into our cartoon
culture yeah the idea of animation
breaking the fourth wall I think we go
with that much easier than lie back so I
think it lends itself to that and also
to be blunt about it I'm worried that
squirrel girls gonna look wrong in
live-action and to sort of make a point
to that I
you don't play Marvel Puzzle Quest do
you I do not you know not okay I do I've
been playing you for one time now couple
of years is it's just a it's just a
color match um
puzzle game but you know you you get all
these characters that you can use and
they have special abilities and Squirrel
Girl is one of them now they have unique
to the game you know images for each of
these characters and when they have a
character normally drawn in a stylized
fashion they try and do them more
realistic hmm and she looks weird and
kind of freaky like to the point that a
friend of mine ooh plays this said that
he had a really hard time convincing his
daughter that she should try squirrel
grow because the first thing she saw was
that image from that game she's like no
she looks freaky I don't like that it's
um it's something about the buck teeth
and realistic you report borders like
that mmm no that doesn't work so that
was kind of the nail to cover me like I
want more Squirrel Girl I think she
needs to be animated to actually sell
this character and have her charm come
through yeah the way that
I can see that yeah I kind of figured
like you you would pick something along
those lines to see why I didn't put up a
list but I completely agree with you and
to your points about fourth wall
breaking and how that sort of like fits
into animated from I'm actually going to
jump a little bit forward on my list but
that segues into the first one that I
will mention which is Deadpool I think
this one's interesting because we almost
had Deadpool the animated series so this
is what I think like it's once the Maher
once the merger once me does the
official lead acquires the Fox
properties x-men Fantastic Four they're
going to reboot them they're gonna start
over from the way a lot of people
wouldn't like you know their Deadpool is
still kind of on a hot streak what are
you gonna do with him are you just gonna
scrap that we have kind of made the
point that you could make another
Deadpool movie because of the weird
fourth wall breaking like the nature of
the character lends himself to pointing
out that hey what studio is producing
this movie or didn't a different actor
play you last time or something like
that are we still allowed to say this
now that they're all by Disney right
right but I think and like they leave
you know Deadpool to or if they had
permit I don't think they will at this
point making like an x-force but if they
were to do something
leave that character there but you could
continue that series or just a different
interpretation of the character still
had Ryan Reynolds do the voice you can
bring back so they're curious and make
it an r-rated animated feature you know
the kind that you would rarely see going
to the theaters but I think enough
people went to the theater to see an
r-rated superhero movie like Deadpool
and Logan yeah those movies made money
you gotta imagine an animated feature
could still have a good production value
but cost-prohibitive Lee less ya know
the return wouldn't have to be as much
but would Disney do that's a good thing
that r-rated animated feature and
outsource it to one of their smaller I
was gonna say the only way they do that
is if they don't follow socks animation
into Disney because if it has to in any
way carry a brand that if not as Disney
itself is a Disney
adjacent brand like if it carried a
Pixar label or anything like that that
no they would never ever ever let that
happen or you could do at a pg-13 the
comics have been doing it of kids you 13
I mean I I would say that you because
here's the funny thing in animation you
are actually allowed to get away with a
lot worse stuff so like it's really
weird to me that now DC animated movies
have good like gotten into being r-rated
which is dumb because if you look at the
pg-13 stuff like a son of Batman and
throne of Atlantis that is bloody as
head so while they may have to tone down
the language and and the Deadpool movies
haven't been actually particularly
sexually explicit so as long as they
dial back the language they could
actually get away with being as violent
in a cartoon as they have been in
live-action movies and get away with a
pg-13 I mean we're seeing that already
right so I I don't I think if you went
animated I don't think it would I should
be as much of a hit on on Deadpool to
get a pg-13 yeah
and I think the same fanbase would turn
in for an animated Deadpool movie I
don't think you would lose that many
fans just be careful like fans of that
particular character of that property I
think if you said it's still we're
getting Ryan Reynolds in Morena Baccarin
or whoever like to come back they're
still voicing the same characters or
something and we'll just transfer it
making it a little this is certainly an
animator or cartoonish or something like
that I don't think the audience takes
such a hit no no I think that's fair
yeah so next one I'm gonna get more
specific with this not only do I think
this should be animated I'm gonna give
you a style this should be animated okay
this should be done in anime style okay
and that's Ghost Rider I had him on my
list ooh
okay well then we can compare visions
for this okay because in my mind you do
Ghost Rider like one of the bizarre
bonkers I'm not saying necessarily do it
already but in the style of the r-rated
style animes from the 80s and 90s things
like a
Kirra in wicked city I was thinking like
a vampire hunter d or something like
that and even even their contemporaries
like the Netflix Castlevania type of
thing yes I think I think Ghost Rider
would be perfect for something like that
because that has been one of the many
problems with live-action adaptations is
Ghost Rider himself looks good
everything else looks like crap because
they have to pour all the money into how
expensive that effect is which is why
they took Blackheart a character who's
basically only distinguishable by his
very unique look and having just played
by wes Bentley and got in a goth outfit
so you know oh god do you talk about a
character custom-built for anime style
animation bring black art back and doing
it right sure yeah all the demons and
and everything I mean you could do a
whole spirits of vengeance thing with
with bringing lilith and the vampires
and everything oh yeah but yeah no I I
was writing there I was thinking could
they do some of the horror properties in
particularly Ghost Rider and the visual
effects with the motorcycle flavors gone
awry
and what kind of animated style would
have fit and that was my first thought
was like vampire hundred deep yeah like
something like that like that kind of
anime style from that particular era
that house yeah I'm right there with you
yeah yeah so that's fun of me we both
kind of locked in on that one okay so
I'm gonna depart from Marvel just
briefly okay cuz this is what I've
talked about this property before and
I've talked about how I think you could
do it as a film and I stand by what I
said when I did that but I do think if
you did it animated as a TV series
there's one specific aspect of the
comics that you could bring into an
animated adaptation of it that Sandman
mmm okay because one of the interesting
things about Sandman is I mean at this
point you buy it it's in trades sure
basically every volume had a new artist
and every volume had a new art style
imagine an animated show where every
season was in a new art style and I
think something like Sandman which is
ultimately a story about stories right
it's it's all about the power of stories
and how stories shape our lives that
each new season is a new story in a new
style
and I think it's just I don't have it
more fleshed out than that but I think
just adding that element into a Sandman
adaptation would be really cool and it's
something I think you could do like in
an animated TV format that just what is
an aspect that simply just gets lost
when you translate to live-action
I I agree I definitely yeah and I hadn't
I hadn't thought about that but it makes
perfect sense and yeah if I was going to
approach an adaptation of that because
of the scope of the original saga and
trying to be on there that and be
truthful to that it would take a massive
undertaking to do it live action
but approach it with an animated style
of different looks different styles
different visual language every season
or every story arc that could be really
really cool too so I'm down with Allen
cool my next one going back to Marvel a
very different style now different from
Deadpool for Ghost Rider from Sandman
everything like that
going back to very kid-friendly very kid
said this would be a kids movie and they
it's a property that Marvel has talked
about maybe we'll do this face for face
by there's a lot of action thing I
actually think it would be really cool
as a animated kids property and it is
the powerpack okay I know this name I
don't know that and I actually I haven't
read a whole lot of them either I'm add
that familiar although I would recommend
there's a podcast dedicated to the
comics and the characters hosted by two
guys named Jeff and Rick it's called
unpacking the power of the power pack
which is the name that packs a lot of
power essentially it's a family it's for
kids their last name is power and each
one of the kids has a did like it's it's
not unlike the Fantastic Four they're
caught up in the we're kind of
experiment each one of them has a
slightly different power each one has a
different personality traits and all
these little things in there because
their family their siblings of two boys
two girls the way they interact and play
off each other you could incorporate all
of the stuff from the kid the kind of
the kids cartoons that we grew up with
from superhero tropes to Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles to all of these other
things
but I really think something like that
don't bring it into the same Marvel
Cinematic Universe that just had the
snap shark that broke everything
let that be a cartoon for that
particular you know preteen age group
that you know really like you know six
to twelve year old age group I think
would really get something out of this
and that's not to this marriage or say
like that the characters aren't worthy
of adult stories cuz again I don't know
enough about their story content to
really make a judgment on that I'm just
saying what I do know about them I think
they would lend themselves really well
to a kids animated movie so alright so
I've got about one more angle I've got
like one moral toss off of Aryan but
I've got one that basically I basically
bring up absolutely anytime I'm like
these should be made in a movie that
went just mentis a friggin movie again
and I'm now crossing my fingers that we
could possibly springboard this off of
into the spider-verse and that's
spider-man 2099 so look here's the thing
as much as I I like thinking there's
absolutely no reason you could not do
that that live-action and have it go
well the simple truth is that but it's a
spin-off character yeah and the cost of
properly realizing not only the
character but that world cuz you've got
to you basically got to build the Blade
Runner yeah world from the ground up in
addition to having a superhero who is
doing all this swing so you you've
basically got to have the combined
budget of Blade Runner
20:49 and spider-man homecoming that's a
little cost prohibitive especially with
somebody who is just to spin off
character you do it animated you
immediately control the cost without
having to sacrifice the world that he
lives in which as much as I love Miguel
O'Hara as a character half the appeal of
that is the world that he is not rating
in and you know beyond just the appeal
of him as as the hero yeah
that is the question and it would not
surprise me if into the spider-verse is
a hit I think it would be right if it
lend itself to sequels we know
spider-gwen is going to be a character
in that so my money she's the first one
who gets a spinoff if they did one say
if she if she's a hit and there's no
reason why she shouldn't be I mean she
the fame that there's a fan base for I
don't know anyone who doesn't like
spotlight I know a couple of people like
who are it beyond the concept of her but
like I don't know anyone who looks at
that outfit hears that name and goes
know everyone's like okay look that's
cool
ya know yeah so I would think if into
the spider versus a is that hits I would
love to see them get more spin-off
ancillary spider-man characters and I
think spider one would be the first up
but then maybe spider-man 2099 oh cool I
think I think that would work well so
you you only have the three of the gym
I've got one more and this is sort of a
big kind of more sprawling thing because
it opens up a lot of different avenues
and that is filling in some gaps or just
telling you other stories within the the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
okay starring the characters that we
know but more or less disposable stories
so you could let me loosen up this way
you can have a story about Thor and the
Asgardians
that maybe takes place before the first
door movie or between Thor and Thor the
dark world or between Thor and Thor
Ragnarok and it has the same cast you
did Chris Hemsworth to voice the
character you get some of the same
actors to play that and it's just kind
of doing it's a little thing but it
wouldn't have necessarily the
consequences because you've already got
the chapters before and after so it's
just kind of an in-between little side
adventure to give you more exposure to
this character but it could be just as
easily to to divorce from the main
movies as the Netflix shows or the ABC
TV shows runner it can be part of the
whole world if you want it to be but it
doesn't have to be and you could do that
with Captain America you could do that
with Ironman and really any character
you can flesh out some of the other ones
I actually thought this was
depending on where they go if they end
up making a Nova movie one of the things
that I thought would be cool for an oval
origin and this could be done animated
or as the live-action but for the
purposes of this it would be an animated
one is actually started with what was
mentioned in infinity war which is Thea
notices destruction of Zam gnar and
wiping out the Nova Corps to get the
Power Stone yeah and basically taking
that woman and then transplanting the
seed from the comic book invasion
annihilation storyline okay which showed
the annihilation wave and miles wiping
out the gore and all of the power from
all of the other Nova's who were dead
went into the one last living Nova
basically had the same type of thing
doing it you've only got one Nova Corps
member left alive except in this case
instead of the annihilation it was
because of Thanos wiping out shandaar
and that kind of being the springboard
for the origin for this character I
would like to see that a live action but
for these purposes it could also be a
cool animated feature and like the Green
Lantern animated series that came out
wherever you could do a lot of cool
space-based adventures in an animated
format select springing off of those
another way of doing the same thing with
these characters if you didn't want to
tie them to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe or if you didn't if you
couldn't get the the same actors to come
back and voice them I think now that
we're at a point where like spider-man
and like iseman there is enough fan
support for the Avengers characters like
with merchandising with just general
name recognition I think they could do
in animated Captain America movie or an
animated the Iron Man movie or whatever
and again thinking like this the budget
for this is not going to be the same
thing as a live-action movie now so your
return doesn't have to be half a billion
dollars no no it does what I think there
there is enough of a market that these
would not be wasted efforts or lost
leaders well I think additionally it
wouldn't be a bad idea with Disney
planning to launch its own streaming
service those will be the
two projects that will beat pretty good
things to put on as exclusives to that
streaming so a bit like what what is it
DC University whatever it is is trying
to do with bringing back Young Justice
and with the Titan showroom so that's
that's my immediate thought for how that
fits into Disney's business model
because I think if you go at the at
record release and stuff like that you
do risk flat-out overload yeah but I
think making those available on a
streaming service and making them
exclusive to that it gives you cuz
Disney already hasn't especially with
having now acquired Fox has an amazing
catalog of stuff that they can make it
available on that but if they can offer
exclusive stuff like that as well that's
that's a good sell and interestingly I
don't know I don't know if you and I've
ever talked about how boy but the
Hellboy franchisee did something similar
to what you're talking about because
they released two direct-to-dvd and I
also showed on Cartoon Network animated
films that I believe came out between
the 1st and the 2nd okay they were they
wanted to do a third one but then by
then I think the second movie had
happened and didn't have the returns
that they wanted they weren't gonna do a
third one in there like that that didn't
happen but yeah and I actually own both
of these and I like them more than the
first Hellboy movie actually I wasn't a
fan of either the Hellboy movies unless
I like that I like I like the second one
but I like these more it's it's blood
and iron and Storm of Swords okay and
they've got the exact same voice cast
coming back you've got Ron Perlman
you've got Doug Jones okay they're all
they're all back voicing these
characters and I and I thought it was
great I thought it worked
so I there is even a template I mean you
could say it didn't work cuz they didn't
keep doing it but that was cuz the
franchise as a whole kind of deflated
but I think there is a template and
there's a precedent for doing something
along those lines I think that's really
cool yeah I mean I was just thinking
that's I don't know if we're gonna get
another four movie and I felt like the
last one finally got the tone that a lot
of fans wanted and I think they at least
they at least find out that this version
of Thor and Chris Hemsworth in
particular is really funny yeah
when you play to that strength which I
think they've done actually more in The
Avengers movies and in the Ragnarok when
you played that level of four that's a
really entertaining action-adventure
hero that people want to see and I never
get that again I was it yeah that give
you the animated version of that a try
and put him with his friends who were
killed off in the last movie you know
and have them just dude like they're
crazy fighting the rock trolls or going
out into space again and see it's not
the version of Thor I would have asked
for but now that I've seen it it's what
I want more oh yeah exactly
I'm the I'm the same way I was like this
isn't mother this they never really gave
me the floor that I want but that would
at least I would watch again yeah um so
I've got one more that I'm just gonna
toss this one off and I'm not gonna go
into a ton of detail because of spoilers
for this particular property okay but
anyone who knows this property will get
why I'm saying this pretty much off the
bat and if you don't just go read it
animal man okay particularly the Grant
Morrison run of Animal Man and sort of
just read back to what we said about
fourth wall breaking yeah the level of
wall breakage of that particular first
one but yeah I don't I I I feel like if
they ever tried to pull off what that
art pulled off in live-action audiences
would rebel I think if you did it in
animation you could get away without
getting into spoilers then yeah it's
it's an animation but it has to pull a
little head flip like the lego movie
does yeah and yeah so again if you read
it you'll understand that would be
interesting it would be fun
so I think that that's all I had um so
Ryan thanks for coming on back and with
me and thank you for joining us for so
what what do you think of any of the
stuff will we picture what comic what
property do you think would be best
suited for animation whatever it is drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it there's a whole bunch of
buttons and stuff and links down there
including want to my patreon so feel
free to check those out and explore
around there and remember folks you are
the council and I just run the me
so until next time this council is
adjourned I'm never letting you intro
again you said I was the counseling
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]